[Music]
welcome
to the explainer zone yes the explainer
itself
yeah yeah not the twilight zone that's
the twilight zone we're confused at the
end
right the explainer zone where you come
out knowing more than you get when you
win
some stuff right and so i think there's
no end to this just so you know
good i will i'll be calling you forever
all right so i want to talk about the
sun the color of the sun
okay all right well you know me i don't
see color
you don't see color sorry we're already
done here
so so so here's the thing
if you're a schoolchild and you to draw
a scene
and you want to put the sun in the sky
what crayon do you reach for
um well i was a very depressed child so
black
black uh okay no you knew about black
holes but yeah
exactly no oh it's always a big yellow
it's always yellow and this is this
notion has been with us since childhood
that the sun is yellow yes and
that's not true it's not even
close to being true uh-oh and
so yeah i'm sorry you know i don't want
to
are you saying that are there any kids
watching please
uh you might want to leave the room
right now
because we're not sure if there's a
crayola available
for you to draw your little scenes with
the house and the grass okay
so here's the thing the sun in broad
daylight
is too bright to look at all right
without risking damaging your eyes so
unless of course you have perfect eyes
so so you don't do it all right so when
is the
time most people ever find themselves
looking directly at the sun when is that
well the only times
i've ever done it is sunset and sunrise
sunday
exactly exactly so not only do we have
the yellow crayon
in our crayon box from childhood anytime
we actually
ever find ourselves looking at the sun
either on purpose or by accident
it's low on the horizon the sun is
rising or setting
and it has a deep yellow color
sometimes it's so deep it can be red
amber into red
yeah so and we know the sun isn't red of
course
it's not red we know that's this isn't
krypton
it's not krypton exactly what they're
red sun
so you you know intuitively it's not red
but somehow you don't know intuitively
that it's also not yellow
okay what color is the sun it is white
now now come on man why you gotta do
that white
see what what just like everything else
all of a sudden chuck not everything
we got commentary you know what
seriously we gotta
must we whitewash all of history
including the sun
really so
yeah so it's not yellow okay it's not
yellow
now i can give you evidence of this
if you need evidence but i'm simply
saying that as the sun gets
let's look at earth and and there's the
atmosphere wrapped around
the earth if the sun is directly
overhead or anywhere near directly
overhead it goes to sort of
let's call that one thickness of
atmosphere okay top to bottom
as the sun gets lower and lower in the
sky
the path of light through the atmosphere
is longer
okay because now you got there's that
angle through it
and the lower the sun gets on the sky
the more and more
atmosphere it has to pass through and in
fact you can calculate
how many equivalent atmospheres it went
through
okay and you just need a little bit of
trigonometry it's a simple calculation
and if it's low on the horizon it goes
through five
six ten equivalent atmospheres gotcha
when it's low on the horizon so whatever
the atmosphere is doing to the sun when
it's high up overhead
it's doing it ten times that and more
when it goes lower on the horizon
okay okay so let's see what the
atmosphere is doing
when the sun is overhead um in comes
white light okay and
[Music]
white light is composed of colors as
isaac newton demonstrated
all the colors of the rainbow red orange
yellow green blue
indigo if you must violence violet okay
so in it comes particles in earth's
atmosphere
that happen to be the same size as the
wavelength of light
of the blue side of the spectrum the
blue indigo purple
violet side of the spectrum those
particles
preferentially scatter the blue
[Music]
out of the sunlight preferentially
scatters it
so it subtracts away a little bit just a
little bit
all right the rest of the light makes it
all the way to earth's surface
but some of the blue gets scattered and
that's why we have a blue sky
nice the blue sky is stolen sunlight
that would have otherwise passed
straight through look at that
okay right because the sky is really
clear right
okay so now watch how beautiful is that
though now let's have the sun get a
little lower in the sky
well there'll be more of this going on
okay
more of the sky that's why on cloudless
days into sunset the sun gets
deeper and deeper and deeper blue the
bluest sky that's why sky blue is light
blue
right all right you want to talk about
sirius right home to mama blue
is the blue sky that surrounds the
twilight curtain of a sunset
now you're talking blue right okay so
so much blue is taken out
that we now roy g biv red orange yellow
green blue and he took out
blue indigo violet what's left red
orange yellow green okay if you add
those colors together
you're gonna get an amber sun
and depending on how how many particles
there are you'll get a red sun or you'll
get a
simple yellow sun right on the horizon
and so you now look at so oh we have a
yellow star look it's yellow
oh no it's the atmosphere made it yellow
okay it's lying to you
and if you so here's what you do broad
daylight if there's thin cirrus clouds
okay so it's safer to look up to the sun
look up the sun in the middle of the day
is it yellow no no
it is white this is very disturbing
this is very very disturbing because the
clouds themselves don't change the color
of the sun it'll just it just dims it
so you look at a slightly dimmer sun uh
behind the cl thin clouds as they pass
it's not yellow
not only that consider the following
all right now this takes a little extra
thinking put your thinking cap on
okay and we in another explainer we
addressed this but now
there's a different reason for it if i
have a
sheet of paper and it's white
that means light reflected of it from it
is an even mixture an equal mixture of
red orange yellow green blue violet
all those colors together in
optics makes white don't tell this to an
artist right it doesn't it doesn't
work on the ease no it's they you do
it's just the opposite in all right
it's just the opposite you don't get
black but you'll get like slush
you'll get sludge right all right so the
fact that the page is white
means all of those colors of light are
hitting that page
so that when they reflect up you see
white okay so
a white light illuminating a white piece
of paper
shows up to you as a white piece of
paper there you go
okay now white reflects all colors
let me put a a red gel in front of
the light now look at the paper what
color is it
it's red it's red kind of pinkish but
yeah that's right so it reflects all
colors but now it's only getting red
it's going to reflect the red it
reflects all colors
the page is red right your eye
okay let's put a blue gel what happens
to the page the page is blue same thing
yeah
okay so if the sun
were yellow then
snow would be yellow yellow
which by the way sometimes snow is
yellow and it's not from the sun
and whatever you do whatever you do
don't eat the yellow stay away from that
snow
the fact that snow looks white
right is evidence that it's being
illuminated by
white light wow that white light is
either sunlight or a moonlight
that's right which is also reflection of
sunlight it's just reflected sunlight
there you go this is so disturbing
so so so i'm just trying to be
honest i'm just trying to put it out
there
and just and by the way let me take you
want to go up a notch
are you ready to go up a notch on this i
don't know if i'm ready to go up a notch
i don't think you're ready okay so
um white is the sun
i hate where this is going already
relative to
incandescent bulbs right okay your kids
will have no memory of incandescent
bulbs but old-timers
if you're over 25 you're an old-timer
you remember
bulbs that would get hot when you put
them in it was a bulb with a little
piece of wire in it
okay i used to light up
this sounds like a ken burn special guy
on the porch
right i remember the days where they had
a bulb with a little piece of wire
now that wow would light up and get hot
now first look like magic
[Laughter]
okay we gotta put you on the list of the
next ken burns special the origin of the
light bulbs
uh so all right so where it was and i
forgot what okay okay you're saying
incandescent bulbs okay bulbs
incandescent bulbs when you turn them on
the temperature of the filament is not
as high as the temperature
of the surface of the sun and so the
higher the temperature the more
full that spectrum becomes so if you
look at the spectrum of a bulb
in your house or an incandescent bulb
it's very weak in the blue section
there's some blue there
which is why blue still looks blue under
that light but the blue is
very weak under an incandescent light
bulb
okay so if you bring out
film that needs the full complement of
blue
and you take a picture under
incandescent lights everything is going
to be red
that film if it needed the blue is
called daylight film
this is why there's a difference again
i'm only talking old timers here there
was indoor film
and tungsten film and outdoor film
and the outdoor film was color balanced
to get the entire spectrum
of the sunlight if you took indoor film
and put it outside
that indoor film is too sensitive to
blue because it's making up for the
feeble blue coming out of a bulb and it
goes out it's getting all the blue it
ever wanted if you have indoor film took
a picture outside everything looks blue
because it was hypersensitive to blue
and the sun has plenty of it
okay so to a photographer
sunlight is blue it's highly blue
and they have to correct for that if
they're going from indoors to outdoors
they have to redo
the color balance on a white sheet of
paper to account for the difference
between indoor lighting and outdoor
lighting
now here's where they all got it wrong
but they're not going to change it
because they're deep into it you ready
now we have the blending of science and
technology with art
you ready here it is if an artist
draws an arctic scene what color is
prevalent
white and what color blue
blue right if an artist draws
dante's hell what color is prevalent red
and orange red and orange okay
so emotionally we think of blue as cold
and red is hot
photographers will tell you
we need to reduce the temperature of the
light
which means make it colder emotionally
but the only way to do that is to get
more blue in it which means
upping the temperature of the tungsten
that they have
shining on you or to put more blue into
it and in the old days that meant a
hotter light bulb
so they said we need a cooler scene they
had to have a hotter bulb
we need a warmer scene they had to have
a colder bulb to do that
wow and that language is still embedded
in that entire profession
yep that is true the the opposites and
they meet in the middle and they deal
with it
opposites of art and technology and
science and and the physics of light
all right we got to call it quits there
all righty always good to have you chuck
always a pleasure this has been the
explainer zone i'm sticking with it
i like it so keep looking up
[Music]
you